hi this is Wally Wingert I'm playing the
Riddler in Batman Arkham underworld the
Riddler is more nerd type villain he's
this guy named Edward nygma enigma it
becomes a game to him to lure Batman
into certain traps by using the
intellect that he just knows Batman will
never figure out and of course Batman
his result will die Batman always
figures it out unlike the other games
we're playing all the hero characters
this game you're actually playing as a
bad guy which finally we who voiced bad
guys finally say yes finally somebody
gets to play as us and we get to rue the
day we get to save the day he comes
loaded with a lot of firepower and a lot
of great intellectual stuff that he will
use including the hologram which is
great he can toss a hologram over the
corner everybody will run to that he can
sneak in then blow the guys away with
what he had why is a woman in love like
a welder they both carry a torch because
it's so well written the 8 of us go
forth not back to protect the King from
a foes attack pawns you imbecile there
are guys who sit up all night with their
computers writing this stuff it's just
absolutely brilliant and we'll come into
a session and see these lines I'm like
oh my gosh this is amazing
who left this mental Lac wood in charge
I have billions of eyes yet I live in
darkness I have millions of ears yet
only four lobes
I have no muscle yet I rule two
hemispheres what am i it's the human
brain idiot The Riddler does go into
those dark places from time to time for
example the line from the game is how do
you stop a dog from barking in July easy
you shoot the dog in June he just revels
in saying this weird dark stuff but with
such joviality come back Batman I have
more riddles for you this is the Riddler
speaking inviting you to play batman
arkham underworld do you have what it
takes
can you riddle with the best me the
Riddler prove it
you